- Welcome back, everybody.
Obviously my little girl
came to visit me onset,
well, 'cause the set's in our home.
This next guy though, I'm about to dial in
is a real Texas gentleman.
You've enjoyed him on
the "Blue Comedy Tour,"
"Dancing With the Stars"
and the "Bill Engvall Show."
These days you can check
him out on Facebook Live,
and in "Last Man Standing."
Are you there, Bill?
- Oh, hey, Kell.
- Hi, my little girl
literally just came in.
I don't know if you were napping,
but she came in for a little.
She was like, "Who are you talking to?"
This is Bill, this is River.
- Hi.
- River, you don't know me, River.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Hey River, do me a favor and smile.
(Kelly laughing)
Well, you know what?
You need to call the police. (laughs)
'Cause someone has stole
some of your teeth.
- (laughing) They stole 'em!
She's just like Mama.
I lost my two front teeth the same time.
Alright, I'm gonna do
this interview, alright?
- Okay, bye.
- I love you.
- Nice meeting you, River.
- Her birthday is Friday.
She's very excited.
- How are you, Kell?
- I'm good!
How are you doing?
- Well, I just want you to know,
that you're the only person
that I will shower in the
middle of the day for.
- (laughs) I gotta be honest with you.
I don't even know if that
person exists for me.
(both laughing)